في العناوين
ما بعد الزلزال جهود مستمره في سوريا
لانقاذ العالقين والبحث عن ناجين تحت
الانقاض اعداد الضحايا تقارب الثلاثه الاف
قتيل واكثر من خمسه الاف مصاب والدفاع
المدني يحذر من ارتفاع مضطرد في عدد
الوفيات شمال غربي البلاد بسبب قله
الامكانات
وعلى وقع الماساه الامم المتحده تقول ان
مساعداتها تنتظر دخول مناطق شمال غرب
سوريا وتدعو الى تحييد السياسه منسقها
الاقليمي يقول للجزيره انه يامل دخولها
غدا ووزير الخارجيه التركي يؤكد العمل على
فتح معبرين اضافيين دمشق تطلب العون من
الاتحاد الاوروبي والمفوضيه الاوروبيه
تتحدث عن مؤتمر للمانحين
وفي تركيا ضحايا الزلزال يقتربون من عتبه
العشره الاف قتيل واكثر من 50 الف جريح
الرئيس التركي يصف ما تواجهه البلاد
بالكارثه الكبرى والسلطات تعلن وصول فرق
انقاذ من 60 دوله
ما بعد زلزال ليس كما قبله ايام مرت على
تركيا وسوريا وما زالت المحاولات جاريه
للبحث عن ناجين وانقاذهم نجاه مرهونه
بعامل الزمن الذي يضيق لحظه بعد لحظه في
المناطق السوريه تبدو المعاناه مضاعفه
ماساه لاحقت بماسات فكثفت النزوحه والفراق
والفقد وفاقمت معضلات لا مجيبه عن متى
ستنتهي
[موسيقى]
حاضر
الله اكبر الله اكبر
[موسيقى]
اذا تتصاعد ارقام ضحايا كل ساعه ومعها
اعداد المصابين المنتشرين احياء الوضع في
المناطق السوريه المنكوبه بالزلزال هو
الاسوا حيث زلزال والبرد وانعدام دخول
المساعدات ومعدات الانقاذ حتى الان ارتفع
عدد القتلى في سوريا الى اكثر من 2900 وفي
سباق مع الزمن يعمل متطوع الدفاع المدني
السوري او فرق الخوذ البيضاء في مناطق
سيطره المعارضه لانتشال ناجين من تحت
الانقاض وتتناقص امالهم باعتبار الايام
الثلاثه الاولى التي تنقضي بعد سويعات
حاسبه كي لا يفقد الاحياء مرونه بالانقاذ
حياتهم كما اكد ذلك نائب مدير الدفاع
المدني منير مصطفى في نشره سابقه للجزيره
بدانا نفقد الامر حقيقه نحن نتجاوز ساعات
العمل ستين ساعه
المصابين تحت الانقراض ذاته عرضه الى ان
يفقدوا ارواحهم جراء عدم وصول فرق القوات
البيضاء اليهم وذلك نتيجه نقص المعدات
التي ناشدنا كل الدول ناشدنا الامم
المتحده ناشدنا الاتحاد الاوروبي ناشدنا
كل الدول حول العالم ان ان ترسل لنا هذه
المعدات لم تصل اي مساعده حقيقيه انا لا
اعرف لماذا الانسانيه لماذا الانسانيه
تتجزا لماذا الوضع الانساني دائما يحسب
على الشعب السوري من الناحيه السياسيه
وينزل عليه من الناحيه السياسيه
هذا كان عن سوريا اما في تركيا فقد بلغت
الهزات الارتداديه منذ زلزال الاثنين 790
هزه وفق نائب الرئيس التركي كما ارتفع عدد
القتلى الى تسعه الاف
وسبعه وخمسين وناهز عدد الجرحى ثلاثه
وخمسين الفا واحصي من المباني المنهاره
سته الاف واربعمائه واربعه واربعون
وتواصلت جهود الانقاذ ومسابقه الساعات
الاخيره من اليوم الثالث لانتشال من بقي
حيا تحت الانقاض حيث تجاوز عدد العاملين
في الفرق الميدانيه الصحيه والامنيه
والانقاذ الحكوميه 100 الف شخص
تبقى لحظات وانتشال الاحياء من تحت
الانقاض بواعث الامل النادره وسط الوضع
الماساوي الذي تزامن فيه الزلزال محاله
طقس سيء تدنت فيه الحراره لما دون الصفر
في مدينه اورفا جنوب البلاد تم انقاذ طفل
بعمر ست سنوات بعدما ظل حبيسا لنحو خمسين
ساعه تحت مبنى مؤلف من خمسه طوابق انهار
بفعل الزلزال
نذهب الى شبكه مراسلينا ينضم الينا من
عزمارين على الحدود السوريه التركيه
مراسلنا صهيب الخلف ومن عزاز في ريف حلب
مراسل وجزيره محمد الجزائري ومن غازي
عنتاب مراسل والجزيره منتصر ابو نبوت
ومرحبا بكم جميعا وابدا معك من عزمارين
صهيب الخلف وتقف في مكان تستمر فيه عمليات
الانقاذ هل من ناجين وخارجين من تحت
الركام
نعم في الساعات الاخيره للاسف لم يعثر لم
تعثر فرقه الدفاع المدني السوري على اي من
الناجين فقط هم يواصلون الحفر في هذا
المكان يمكن للكاميرا ان تقترب حتى تتضح
الصوره اكثر هناك تحديات كبيره يواجهها
رجال الدفاع المدني السوري لان هذا البناء
بني على ارض مائله يعني هي من مستوى اعلى
من المستوى الاخر وبالتالي فان الحفر من
جهه من من عده جهات يزيد من الركام على
الجهه الاخرى لذلك فان العمل هنا يبدو
بطيئا لان متطوعي الدفاع المدنيه يعملون
من جهه واحده
ويحاول ان يصلوا الى الطبقات السفلى من
الطبقات البلوتونيه المتكدسه يحاولون ان
يفتحوا عده ثغرات ومن ثم ينتشر منها من
يجدونه من الضحايا للاسف يعني تاخر الوقت
كثيرا على
ناجين محتملين لكن
متطوعي الدفاع المدني يقولون ان انهم لم
يفقدوا الامل وهم يعملون كما تلاحظون وكما
يتضح على الكاميرا يعملون بايديهم وبمعاول
بسيطه
املا بالعثور على ناجين
ولكي لا
يؤذوا اي احد من الناجين المحتملين
الجرافات توقفت والعمل الان بالايدي رغم
صعوبه المكان رغم كثافه
الحديد الذي بنيت به هذه الدعامات
الباطنيه لكن العمل بالايدي هو الخيار
المفضل هنا
لكي لا يؤذوا اي احد من الناجين المحتملين
كما اسلفت الدفاع المدني يفتقد للكثير من
المعدات لا شك بذلك يقولون انهم لديهم
الطاقات البشريه والتي حصلت خبره كبيره من
خلال العمل
في الاستجابه لغارات النظام السوري
والغارات الروسيه التي تعرضت لها المنطقه
طوال السنوات الماضيه لكن هناك نقص كبير
بالمعدات وقد عاينا قبل قليل
حيث
الجرافات التابعه للدفاع المدني السوري
فتوقف العمل الريثما ارسلت العجله الى
الصيانه واعاده بعد ذلك ثم استانف العمل
حاليا توقفت الجرافات بشكل كامل لكن كما
يتضح في الكاميرا هناك ثغره يحاول يحاول
رجال الدفاع المدني العثور فيها على ايه
على اي شيء يتحرك او ايه حياه محتمله
او حتى لضحايا قضوا تحت الانقاض في هذا
المكان يتوقع انه ما زال هناك بين عشره
وخمسه عشره
شخص بين عشر خمس عشره وخمسه عشر شخص ما
يزالون موجودين هنا تحت الانقاض
وقد انتشلت وقد انتشل رجال الدفاع المدني
خمسه وسبعين
كم العدد النهائي وحاول ان اسال فرق
الدفاع المدني
75 نعم 75 يؤكدون ذلك تم انتشالهم
كان من بينهم شخصان حيان
نعم كان من بينهم
شخصان حيان
و 73 كانوا قد قضوا ساحاول الوصول الى
مقابل الفتحه التي
يحاول الدفاع المدني السوري
يجب العمل بحذر شديد هنا لان اي حصول اي
ذمر نعم نعم الاولويه لكم سوف نعود هل
هناك صوت او اي شعور بشيء يتحرك او
ليس هناك
عملنا نداءات ما في اي صوت ما في اي
استجابه
نعم
ما في اي استجابه بس على امل اشوف الوضع
ان شاء الله يا رب ان شاء الله توصلوا
لحدا على قيد الحياه
نعم في هذه القريه الكثير من الابنيه التي
دمرت لكنها متفرقه ليست على امتداد واحد
نحن هنا نعاين بنائين اثنين
وايضا هناك بناءان في الجوار وفي داخل
القريه ايضا عده ابنيه
ما تزال فرق الدفاع تعمل هنا لكنها انهت
العمل في المواقع الاخرى لذلك فهي تكثف
عملها هنا طبعا هذه المنطقه قريبه من
الحدود السوريه التركيه
قريبه من بلده من مدينه سلقين حيث في تلك
المدينه العديد من المواقع التي ما تزال
فرق الدفاع المدني تعمل فيها وتوقع ان
تحتها عالقين تحت الانقاض تحت انقاض
منازلهم قريبه من بلده حارم هذه المدن
الرئيسيه التي كانت مكتظه بالسكان والتي
قصدها النازحون منذ بدايه الثوره السوريه
لكن حدوث الزلزال طبعا
ترك عدد كبير من الضحايا لان جميع البيوت
وجميع الشقق في هذه المناطق كانت ماهوله
بالسكان بسبب الاقتضاض الشديد في هذه
المنطقه الحدوديه
متابعه مجريات الانقاذ
واذهب الان الى اعزاز ومحمد الجزائريه كيف
تبدو المعطيات لديك محمد
نعم سلمى في الحقيقه الوضع ماساوي هنا في
هذه المنطقه نحن الان في الحديقه العامه
في مدينه اعزاز التي نصب فيها المتطوعون
متطوعون عملوا يعملون بشكل طوعي عدد من
القيام داخل هذه الحديقه لاستقبال الاهالي
المتضررين من الزلزال الذين فقدوا منازلهم
او فقدوا او متصدعه نشاهد هنا القيام خلفي
هذه القيام كل خيمه تاوي اقل في اقل
احصائيات ثلاثه عائلات داخلها هذه الفرق
الانسانيه او المتطوعون يعملون على ايواء
هؤلاء الاهالي وتنظيم عمل
المنظمات الانسانيه والفرق الانسانيه في
تقديم المساعدات حقيقه هؤلاء المتطوعون
يعملون على الشبكه بنمط شبكه متكامله قسم
منهم يكون عند مداخل الابنيه مداخل
المدينه يستقبلون المتضررين من مداخل
المدينه
يتوجهون يوجهونهم الى المواقع الاستقبال
المؤقته والتي تم انشاؤه وهي تقدر عددها
باكثر من خمسه عشر
نقطه
في هذه المدينه تستقبل عدد كبير من
العائلات المتضرره جراء
زلزال جراء هذه دمار منازلهم
الدمار الكبير الذي حصل فيها هذه المدينه
استقبلت اكثر من 4000 عائله عملها الى عمل
الفرقيه هي استقبال العائلات وتقديم لهم
ما امكن من التبرعات التي لا يتم جمعها من
الاهالي في المنطقه بالاضافه الى تنظيم
عمل المنظمات الانسانيه بتقديم المساعدات
المنظمات الانسانيه تقوم بتقديم بعض
الوجبات الغذائيه الاغذيه المواد التدفئه
وهذه بعض من هذه الخيام ومن ثم يتم نقل
هؤلاء المتضررين الى نقاط
هنا بدايه الماساه الاهالي عندما يستيقظون
من هول الصدمه التي يعيشونها سينظرون
الاقامه ربما تكون المخيمات التي تعيش
الماساه منذ سنوات والمشهد ايضا كذلك ربما
في غازي عنتاب عند منتصر ابوه نبوت وانت
تقف ايضا يبدو في مكان كالحديقه يبدو هناك
خيام لاواء النازحين
صحيح سلمى المشهد متشابه والمعاناه واحده
هذه احدى الحدائق الكبرى في مدينه غازي
عنتاب وقد شهدت اقبالا كبيرا لمئات
الاشخاص الذين هربوا بمنازلهم بعد هذا
الزلزال تجمعوا في البدايه على شكل
مجموعات وقاموا باشعال النيران خلال
اليومين الماضيين ثم منهم ومنهم من جاء
بسيارته ووضع عائلته داخل هذه السياره من
اجل ان يحميهم من البرد لان درجات الحراره
هي ما دون صفر اليوم شهدت هذه الحديقه
وقبل قريه تطور وهو نصب خيام جديده
للاشخاص الذين يتواجدون في هذه
الحديقه نشاهد هذه هذه الساحه كانت ساحه
للعب الاطفال الان بالقرب منها يوجد عشرات
الخيام قد نصبت كما نشاهد وقد شاهدنا
اعدادا كبيره من الناس يهرعون الى هذا
المكان في محاوله من الحصول على هذه
الخيام او الحصول الحصول العوائل على
القيام لان عدد القيام لا يبدو انه كبير
وهناك هناك يعني وقت كبير قد تحتاجه نصب
جميع الخيام التي وصلت الى هذا المكان
والعادات الناس كبيره بالقرب من هذا
المكان والقرب من هذه القيم يوجد مركز
الايواء وهو يعني كان
صاله تتبع لبلديه غازي عين تاب هذه الصاله
تحولت الى يعني تحولت الى مركز النازحين
وقامت بلديه غازي عنتاب بتوفير بعض
المستلزمات الاساسيه واهمها الدفع الذي
يحاول كل شخص في هذا المكان ان يحصل عليه
بسبب درجات الحراره المتدميه لنشاهد هذا
المنظر الجديد الذي لم نعاهده في مدينه
غازي عنتاب التركيه نحن نتحدث عن منطقه
كانت يعني تعيش بامان ولا يوجد اي داعي
لوجود الخيام لكن اليوم نشاهد هذه الخيام
هذه الحديقه تعتبر من الحدائق المهمه
والكبيره في مدينه غازي عنتاب اصبحت مكانا
للنازحين ايضا يحاولون بناء هذه الخيام
يعني على بعد مناسب من الابنيه المحيطه
لهذه الحديقه في حال حدث زلزال لا سمح
الله لا تتاثر هذه الخيام ولا يسقط اي
ضحايا نشاهد هنا بعض الاشخاص يقومون
باشعال النيران من اجل الحصول على الدفع
ايضا العائلات تحاول في هذه في هذه
المنطقه تحاول في هذه المنطقه ان تبدا
بالسكن والعيش في هذه الخيام كما نشاهد
وايضا يعني هنالك قيام موجوده في الجانب
الاخر يتم الان نصبها في تلك الجهه نشاهد
تلك الخيام لا ادري ان كانت الصوره واضحه
على بعد 800 متر من هذه من هذه المنطقه
سقط مبنى
عمليات النازحين والمتضررين
هو الذي ما زال حتى هذه هذه سنكون معك في
المتابعه منتصر ابو نبوت من غازي عنتاب
وايضا محمد الجزائري من اعزاز في ريف حلب
ومن عزمارين على الحدود السوريه التركيه
صهيب الخلف شكرا لكم جميعا
تجدوا فرق الانقاذ نفسها في سباق مع الزمن
للوصول الى اكبر عدد من الناجين باعتبار
عامل الوقت حاسما وتتضائل مع مروره فرص
انقاذ عالقين تحت الانقاض ويبقى تحديد
موعد لوقف عمليات الانقاذ بدوره حساسا
وصعبا ويخضع لظروف وعوامل عديده نستعرض
معركه البحث والانقاذ وما يحدد خياراتها
مع الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوبيه تركيا وشمال
سوريا في هذا التقرير
قبل 13 عاما عاشت هايتي زلزالا مدمرا
تجاوز 7 درجات على سلم ريختر وعوده بحياه
نحو 200 الف شخص وشرد نحو مليونين وبعد
تسعه ايام اعلنت الحكومه الهايتيه انتهاء
مرحله البحث والانقاذ مع تضاؤل فرص العثور
على المزيد من الاشخاص على قيد الحياه قله
من الاشخاص المحاصرين يمكنهم البقاء على
قيد الحياه لمده طويله خلال الزلازل واول
اثنتين وسبعين ساعه تعد حرجه لانها توفر
اعلى فرص لوجود نجيم لكن يتعين على اجهزه
التنسيق في البلد المتضرر اتخاذ القرار
الصعب بشان متى تتوقف عن البحث عن الاشخاص
المحاصرين المتبقين تحت الانقاض متوسط
الوقت لذلك عاده ما يرابح بين خمسه ايام
وسبعه ويعتمد على عوامل مثل الطقس والهزات
الارتداديه ومدى سرعه وصول فرق الانقاذ
والمعدات لكن تقديرات خبراء في الزلازل
تشير الى ان الافراد يظلون على قيد الحياه
لمده تصل الى 13 يوما اذا كان لديهم
امكانيه الوصول الى الماء واكثر من ذلك
اذا ما وفر لهم الطعام العامل الاكثر
الحاحا هو الحصول على رعايه الطبيه
للاشخاص تحت المباني المنهره قبل انهيار
اجسادهم او نسفهم وفضل لحاله الطقس
الحاليه يعد انخفاض درجه حراره الجسم امرا
ممكنا وربما يموت الناس للاسف بسبب ذلك
وبدون ماء قد يفقد الكثير منهم حياتهم
تلتزم بعض فرق الانقاذ الدوليه ما يعرف
بقاعده الاربعه وتفترض بقاء المحاصرين تحت
الانقاض على قيد الحياه لمده اربع دقائق
دون هواء واربعه ايام دون ماء واربعه
اسابيع دون طعام وتتحدث عن 48 ساعه ذهبيه
يبقى القول ان وقف عمليه الانقاذ قرار صعب
الا انه بالمقابل يسمح بتركيز الموارد على
رعايه الالاف من الناجين الاخرين وع
التعافي والمساعده في ازاله الانقاض لهذا
ووفق بروتوكولات دوليه معتمده يجب ان يكون
عمال الانقاذ سريعين لتقييم الاماكن التي
من المرجح ان يجدوا فيها ناجين داخل
المباني المنهاره ويمكن الاستفاده من
كاميرات الفيديو عبر الفجوات الموجوده في
الانقاض ومعدات التصوير الحراري لتحديد
اماكن الناجين ويمكن لمعدات الصوت
المتخصصه اكتشاف اضعف الاصوات في نطاق
امتار قليله وتعد الكلاب المدربه فعاله
للغايه باستخدام حاسه الشم في كشف ناجين
ناهيك بتعاون المجتمعات المحليه في تحديد
الاماكن ويمكن ايضا استخدام اجهزه الكشف
عن ثاني اكسيد الكربون للعثور على الناجين
الذين فقدوا الوعي حيث يكتشف المنقذون
تركيزه في الهواء عند نفسه ممن مازالوا
يتنفسون
معنا من شمال ادلب عمار السلمو المتطوع في
الدفاع المدني السوري سيد عمار مرحبا بك
معنا مواقع عمليات البحث والانقاذ في
مناطق شمال السوريه المتضرره
تحيه طيبه اهلا ونهارا
[موسيقى]
المعجزات تحدث بكل دقيقه بكل لحظه ما زلنا
نعثر على ناجين تحت الانقاض فقط من ساعات
استخرجنا رجل على قيد الحياه ما زلنا
نستخرج اشخاص على قيد الحياه بعد مرور
اكثر من 60 ساعه ولكن يعني بعد مرور اكثر
من 72 ساعه تبقى الفرص ضئيله كل ثانيه
الان تمر تاخذ معها جزء كبير من الامل في
ايجاد ناجون لو توفرت المعدات التقنيه لو
توفرت الفرق المدربه
بشكل اكبر
لتم انقاذ لن اقول مئات بالالاف الاشخاص
من تحت الانقاذ لان يعني الجميع كان يسمع
اصوات الناس تحت الانقاض ولكن صعوبه
التوزع على كل تلك المباني كان صعب لعدد
لعدم وجود يعني بعدد كبير وعدم وجود اليات
وعدم وجود
المعدات اللازمه نعمل كاميرات الحراريه لا
نمتلك المعدات الكاميرات الحراريه لا نم
الكثير من المعدات التي تكرهها التفرير
لاننا يعني طلبنا بها ولم نحصل عليها
المعده الكلمات الحراريه قيل لنا انها
تستخدم لاغراض عسكريه اذا لم يوردوها لنا
لن نحصل عليها ابدا خلال عملنا في الانقاذ
حصلنا على معدات الصوت يعني
اكتشاف والصوت الاكتشاف وتتبع الصوت ولكن
ليس
كثير من تلك المعدات متى حصلتم على هذه
المعدات
متى حصلتم على هذه المعدات هل في هذه
الكارثه ام ام تتحدث عن الفتره السابقه
الفتره السابقه يعني كانت تركيز يعني
الدول التي تدعمنا التركيز على الحرب
الحرب منذ ثلاث سنوات كما تعلمين يعني
حالات القصف كانت قليله كان شهريا لا
تتجاوز 150 حاله لذلك كان الدعم هذا
يحيلني سيد عمار الى سؤال
تواصلتم مع الجهات التي عاده ما تدعمكم هل
من اجابات وهل من وصول لاي من المساعدات
التي طلبتموها
طبعا نحن منذ لحظات الزلزال الاولى طالبنا
المجتمع الدولي بتقديم فرق مدربه مع
اجهزتها نعرف ان شرائح تلك الاجهزه
وتوريدها الى سوريا في هذه الاوقات يعني
من الصعب ان تصل الى الوقت وخاصه ان الوقت
يمر كل لحظه هي عداد موت ولكن طالبنا فرق
متخصصه دوليه مع معداتها لتصل اليوم وصل
17 شخص ولكن بدون معدات وصلت من مصر ولكن
بدون بدون اي معدات لن يصل اي شيء من لا
فرق ولا معدات اعتمدنا على
يعني ما يتوفر بين يدينا وما يتوفر عند
الناس تم النبش بين الانقاض احيانا يعني
بدون معدات معدات غذائيه معدات زراعه
ومعدات فلاحه المعدات الثقيله ايضا كانت
قليله في
انجاز مهامنا ولكن ما زلنا يعني نقاتل من
اجل العثور على ناجين وما زلنا يعني نتوقع
وجود ناجين مع التقدم في الوقت وهذه
الساعات الحاسمه ما اكثر ما تحتاجونه
ويعني تطلبون وتلحون الان على وصوله قبل
اي شيء
اظن يعني هناك شقين الشق الاول هو التركيز
على عمليات البحث والانقاذ عدم وصول الفرق
المدربه للحظات الاولى يعني لن نكون فات
الاوان ولكن ما زال هناك فرصه اذا كان
هناك فرق مدربه معداتها وصول او وصول
معدات معدات لن
عمل وصول اليات ثقيله وصول معدات متطوره
لحالات البحث والانقاذ ما نحتاجه هو فرق
مدربه العدد الموجود في شمال غير مسؤوليه
هناك اكثر من 2000 متطوع
ولكن العدد قليل نسبه لعدد المباني المدمر
اكثر من 600 مبنى مدمر لذلك مقارنه بوجود
الاعداد مع المباني المدمره وحجم هناك
جبال من الركام يحتاج الى وقت طويل من اجل
الاستقرار نقل تلك الركام هناك مناطق
احياء بكاملها دمرت على الارض وصول لمنتصر
تلك المناطق صعب جدا بدون تجريف الركام في
بدايه الحي لذلك هناك صعوبات كبيره الطقس
هو من الصعوبات الحاره الحارات الشوارع
الضيقه مثلا في سلقين هناك احياء قديمه
شوارع لا يمكن الوصول الى الناجي لا يمكن
النبج يعني بادوات بسيطه تحتاج الى اليات
رفع
الفطن الاسمنتيه من فوق الناس
اشكرك من شمال ادلب عمار السلمو المتطوع
في الدفاع المدني السوري
في ظل هذه الظروف نشد منسق الامم المتحده
الاقليميه للشؤون الانسانيه للازمه
السوريه مهند هادي نشد دول المانحه لتقديم
المساعدات للمنكوبين من الزلزال في سوريا
اضاف هذه في مقابله على الجزيره ان الشعب
السوري عانى من ويلات الحرب على مدى سنوات
طويله وجاء الزلزال ليفاقم معاناته وهو
بحاجه لاي مساعده ممكنه
بوجه رساله للجميع ليس فقط لكل المشاهدين
على الجزيره لما تنظروا للاطفال وللنساء
ولا كبار السن اللي بعانوا
تخيلوا لا سمح الله انه هدول ناس اقربائكم
تخيلوا انه هدول الناس بخصوكم وليس فقط
اشخاص انتم ما بتعرفوهم يعني حسوا بدنا
الجميع يحس مع الناس سواء دول او حكومات
او شعوب الشعب السوري بحاجه الى الى
مساعده الشعب السوري مر فيها ويلات الحرب
لاكثر من عشر سنين والان الزلزال فوق كل
هذه المعاناه فعلا يعني هذا فوق ما يتحمله
اي اي انسان ونناشد الجميع بمساعده الشعب
السوري وتقديم المساعدات الى الشعب السوري
كما اعرب المنسق الاممي للشؤون الانسانيه
في سوريا مهند هادي في مقابلته على
الجزيره عن امله في ان تتمكن اولى شحنات
المساعدات من العبور يوم غدا الخميس الى
داخل الاراضي السوريه من خلال معبر باب
الهوى
في معوقات لوجستيه كثيره الطرق جزء منها
كبير قد قد تضرر
واصبحت غير يعني اصبحت امكانيه وصول
الشاحنات صعبه لكن المعلومات اللي وصلتنا
بعد ظهر اليوم انه اصبحت الطريق الان
سالكه الى حد ما طبعا مشتركه بالطريقه
اللي كانت قبل قبل الزلزال لكن ممكن انها
الشاحنات تصل الى الحدود وطبعا في
الشاحنات اللي بدها تيجي من المناطق
السوريه ليتم تبديل المواد من من الشاحنات
التركيه الى الشاحنات السوريه نامل وكلنا
امل انه بكره نستطيع انه
نتمم موضوع النقل المساعدات عبر الحدود
وكان المصطفى بن المليح المناسق الانساني
المؤقت للامم المتحده في سوريا قال ان
زلزاله فاقم من معاناه ملايين السوريين
واوضح المصطفى بن المليح في احاطه صحفيه
عبر تقنيه الفيديو انه حتى قبل الزلزال
كانت البنيه التحتيه المتعلقه بالطرق
والمياه والكهرباء والوقود سيئه للغايه
والان اصبحت اسوا وهذا يؤثر على العمل
الانساني ودع المناسق الانساني المؤقت
للامم المتحده في سوريا الى وضع
الاعتبارات السياسيه جانبا والعمل على
البعد الانساني
وفي مقابله مع الجزيره ايضا قالت مديره
مستشفى الامومه في ادلب اكرام حبوش ان
عددا من المشافي خرج عن الخدمه ما فاقم
المعاناه القائمه اصلا في الشمال الغربي
لسوريا واضافت ان شيئا من المساعدات او
فرق الانقاذ لم يدخل بعد من المعابر الى
الداخل السوري
نحن بالاصل عم نعاني من نقص شديد
بالامكانيات وتراجع في الدعم في القطاع
الصحي في شمال غرب سوريا وخاصه بعد ازمه
اوكرانيا هلا انا كقطع نسائيه وتوليد بسبب
انه قسم من مشاكل
تقدم هاي الخدمه طلعت عن العمل مثل المشفى
الامومي في الدانه وباقي المشافي او مشاكل
اخرى فهذا الشيخ اللي عنا ضغط نحن على
المشافي اللي لسا عم نقدم الخدمه ضغط كبير
من ناحيه انه المراجعين باعدادهم الكبير
اللي نحن ما فينا عم نحسن نقدم شيء
عم نحاول قدر الامكان يعني خدمه الولاده
والقيصرين امنهم اياها بس نحن بالنسبه لنا
قسم الحواضن ممتلئ وقسم حديثي الولاده
ممتلئ بس اذا بدنا نحكي على المشاكل اللي
عم تقدم الجراحات وبمشافه اللي عم يصير
عليها اسعاف الجرحى ومصابين
نحن بالاصل بالشمال غير سوريا عدد الاطباء
والمنشات قليل لحد الان المعابر ما دخل
منها ولا فريق انقاذ ولا دخل اي شيء من
المساعدات
ويواجهوا القطاع الصحي في مناطق الشمال
السوريه المنكوبه بالزلزال صعوبه كبيره في
التعامل مع الاعداد الهائله من الاصابات
والحالات الحرجه وتضم المناطق الخاضعه
للسيطره المعارضه في شمال غرب سوريا ما
يزيد عن 500 مؤسسه صحيه ظل اغلبها في
الخدمه بالاعتماد على دعم المانحين
الدوليين
261 من تلك المنشات الطبيه توجد في محافظه
ادلب وتتوزع بين مشاف وعيادات ومراكز
رعايه مختصه لكن تلك المؤسسات الصحيه
جميعها تواجه نقصا في الكادر الطبي بعد ان
غادرها نحو 70% من العاملين فيها بفعل
الحرب بحسب الصليب الاحمر الدولي ما جعل
طبيبا واحدا يخدم نحو عشره الاف شخص من
اصل ما يقرب من اربعه ملايين نسمه وفقا
لتقديرات اداره القطاع الصحي في مناطق
شمال غرب سوريا كما تعاني المشافي في تلك
المناطق قبل كارثه زلزال من نقص حاد في
المستلزمات الصحيه الاساسيه كالاسعافات
الاوليه ومواد التخدير وصفائح المستخدمه
لكسور العظام
ومنذ اليوم الاول لزلزال كهرمان مرعش عاد
الى الواجهه الحديث عن اليه دخول
المساعدات الانسانيه الى سوريا خصوصا في
مناطق الشمال حيث طلبت منظمات دوليه ان
يكون وصول المساعدات دون تقييد حسب وصفها
في التقرير التالي نتعرف على ما بقي من
خيارات يمكن عبرها ادخال المساعدات
بمثل الحاح اقصى ايام الحرب وربما اكثر
تبدو حاجه السوريين الان لمدي يد العون
اليهم في كل شيء خصوصا لانقاذ العالقين
تحت ركام المباني التي هدمها زلزال كهرمان
مراش الدفاع المدني السوري في مناطق
المعارضه شمالا اطلق نداءات عاجله طلبا
للمساعده ومثله فعل النظام ومع ان الظرف
الانسانيه واحد قاهر وعصيب لكن الظروف
السياسيه لكل منطقه من سوريا تفرض نفسها
في هذا الوقت فمناطق المعارضه لديها معبر
واحد يسمح من خلاله بدخول المساعدات
الدوليه بتفويض اممي يجدد كل سته اشهر هو
معبر باب الهوى مع تركيا بعد اصرار الروسي
والنظام السوري على اغلاق معبر باب
السلامه في ريف حلب خلال السنوات الماضيه
اما في مناطق النظام السوري فتكثر
الخيارات البريه منها والجويه وهي مطاره
حلب ودمشق اللذان بدا فعلا باستقبال شحنات
المساعدات المقدمه من دول عربيه وغيرها
اضافه لمعابر بريه مع دول الجوار بحسب و
الخارجيه السوري فيصل المقداد فان
العقوبات الامريكيه المفروضه على النظام
تفاقم من سوء الاوضاع رغم تاكيد الجانب
الامريكي استثناء المساعدات الانسانيه من
تلك العقوبات وهو نفس الاستثناء الذي نص
عليه قرار مجلس الامن الاخير بشان وصول
المساعدات الى سوريا ايضا ابدت جهات سوريه
ومنها الهلال الاحمر السوري العامل في
مناطق النظام استعدادها لايصال المساعدات
الى كل المناطق حتى الخارجه عن سيطره
الحكومه وفق وصفها وهو مطلب لطالما اصر
النظام السوري ومعه روسيا على تحقيقه في
مجلس الامن اي ان يتولى النظام السوري
وتوزيع المساعدات في مناطقه ومناطق
المعارضه عبر ما يطلق عليها ادخال
المساعدات عبر خطوط التماس وهي اليه تعيب
المعارضه منظمات انسانيه في الشمال السوري
عليها ان النظام لا يوصل عبرها من
المساعدات سوى النزر اليسير كما انه يسعى
من خلالها الى تحقيق مكاسب سياسيه الثابت
ان زلزال كهرمان ماراش ادخل الجميع في
مضمار السباق مع الوقت فمع كل تمر يتكشف
الحجم الحقيقي للكارثه سواء في تركيا او
في سوريا
معنى من عمان المتحدثه باسم المفوضيه
ساميه للامم المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين سيده
رولا مرحبا بك معنا اين الاشكاليه التي
تكمن في عدم ادخال المساعدات عبر معبر باب
الهوى حتى الساعه الى شمال السوري
للتوضيح عدم ادخال المساعدات لا يعني انه
لا يوجد مساعدات لان جميع الوكالات الامم
المتحده بما فيها المفوضيه لديها مخازن
داخل شمال غرب سوريا وهناك خيام هناك
مساعدات غثيه والكل لديه هذه
المخازن ولكنها طبعا لا تكفي نظرا
للاحتياجات الجمه التي نجمت عن هذا
الزلزال ولذلك هناك حاجه ماسه لادخال
المزيد المشكله ان الطريق الرئيسي الذي
كانت تستعمله الشاحنات لايصال هذه
المساعدات عبر معبر باب الهوى قد تضرر
بسبب الزلزال وهناك صور يعني واضحه نحن
نامل بان هذا الضرر قد اصلح وانه ستتمكن
الامم المتحنه من ادخال المزيد من
المساعدات الى شمال غرب سوريا غدا او بعد
غد ان شاء الله يعني هناك عمل حديث لاصلاح
هذا الشارع الرئيسي هناك طرق اخرى
يؤدي الى هذا المعبر ولكنها ليست صالحه
للشاحنات الكبيره والتراكات التي تحمل
المساعدات وانت تعلمين انها مساعدات كبيره
فهذه
يعني تستوجب طرق افضل حتى تتمكن هذه
الشاحنه
المعبر مفتوح ولكن ماذا عن المعابر الاخرى
خاصه في ظل وجود مثل هذه الكارثه والحاجه
الماسه للدخول مع تعطل مثلا معبر باب
الهوى بسبب المشكلات التي نجمت عنه
الزلزال والطرق
بقول لك المعابر الاخرى هذا المعبر الذي
معبر باب الهوى الذي تدخل منه المساعدات
هو المساعدات تدخل
بحسب اليه بحسب قرار من مجلس الامن الدولي
هذا القرار صدر قبل اعوام ويتم تجديده كل
سته اشهر يسمح لوكالات الامم المتحده
للاغاثه بان ترسل المساعدات الانسانيه الى
شمال غرب سوريا عبر الحدود مع تركيا وهو
امر عاده لا يحدث يعني الامم المتحده
ملتزمه بان تدخل عبر الحدود الشرعيه وحسب
اتفاقيات مع الحكومه هذا كاس استثناء نظرا
للحاجات الجامه في شمال غرب سوريا
وبالتالي فنحن ملزمون كمنظمات امم متحده
ملزمون بقرارات مجلس الامن التي تتيح لنا
الان استخدام هذا المعبر فقط طيب
رولا يعني حتى المنسق الانسان للامم
المتحده في سوريا
طالب بوضع الاعتبارات السياسيه جانبا يعني
يعني هناك مناشدات حتى من الامم المتحده
بسبب حاجه وحاجه الموقف في الشمال السوري
صحيح وهذه هي مناشده الوكالات ومفاضله
المفوضيه وجميع المنظمات العامله في
المجال مناشده من الذي يعطل
انت سالتيني هذه اللحظه اليمه والاحتياجات
فيها جمع ويجب وضع كل التدخلات السياسيه
والاعتبارات السياسيه على جنب والتركيز
على احتياجات الموجودون على الارض
المنكوبين المنكوبون بفقدان عائلاتهم
واحبائهم وبيوتهم وكل الامان الذي كانوا
يحاولون الوصول اليهم يجب التركيز على
احتياجات هؤلاء
ويعني اعتماد كل الطرق الممكنه لادخال
المساعدات والوصول اليهم باسرع وقت ممكن
باكبر قدر من المساعدات التي يحتاجونها
من هي
الجهات التي قد تعرقل مثل هذا التوجه
اي تواجد توجه ان تستخدم عابر اخرى تحتاج
الى قرار
الموجوده في مجلس الامن والمشاركه في مجلس
الامن هي يجب ان تجتمع وتاخذ قرار بفتح
هذه المعابر للقوافل الاغاثه الانسانيه
يعني لا يوجد الموضوع هو موضوع سياسي كبير
طبعا المجلس الامن والامين العام هم من
يقومون بهذا التحرك لا اعرف باي اتجاه نحن
كمنظمه اغاثيه موجوده على الارض لا ندخل
في هذه النقاشات نحن نحث ونطلب
ونناشد ونقول الحاجات كبيره ورجاء من جميع
الاطراف وجميع الدول وضع الخلافات
السياسيه جانبا ووضع التسجيل النقاط
السياسيه جانبا والتركيز على تلبيه
احتياجات الناس هذه مناشدتنا الامين العام
والمكتب المكتب يعني الجزء في الامم
المتحده المسؤول عن العلاقات السياسيه
ومجلس الامن هو من يقرر ايبت معابر تستطيع
المنظمات الانسانيه استعمالها انت تعلمين
ولا يخفى على احد الامم المتحده وخاصه
المنظمات الانسانيه هي ليست عصا سحريه
يعني نحن ملزمون بما يقرره مجلس الامن
وملزمون بقرارات
وقوانينها
جميعا والدول تلتزم بها شكرا جزيلا لك من
عمان
المتحدثه باسم المفوضيه الساميه للامم
المتحده لشؤون اللاجئين شكرا لك
قالت رئيسه المفوضيه الاوروبيه ارسل انه
يمكن لتركيا وسوريا الاعتماد على الاتحاد
الاوروبي مؤكده
نيه اقامه مؤتمر للمانحين بدايه الشهر
المقبل في هذه الاثناء قلم مفوض الازمات
وطوارئ في الاتحاد الاوروبي
ان النظام السوري قدم طلبا للمساعده وان
الطلبه حول الى الدول الاعضاء واضاف يانزا
ان الاتحاد سيرفع من مستوى الدعم المالي
المقدم للمنظمات الانسانيه في المناطق
المتضرره في شمال سوريا
الاتحاد الاوروبي يمول ويدعم شركائنا من
المنظمات الانسانيه في سوريا منذ اكثر من
عشر سنوات الوضع الانساني هناك سيء بالفعل
والزلزال زاد من فدحه الوضع نرفع مستوى
جهودنا من خلال هذه المنظمات وجهنا جزءا
من انشطتها تجاه هذا الامر نرفع من مستوى
الدعم المالي كذلك للمناطق المتضرره
تلقينا هذا الصباح طلبا من النظام السوري
للمساعده من خلال اليه الطوارئ وشاركنا
ذلك مع الدول الاعضاء ونشجعها على
المساعده
تتعظم ماساه الزلزال الذي ضرب مناطق سوريا
التي تعاني اصلا من ويلات الحرب
وتداعياتها القاسيه تتعدد الاسباب التي
تجعل وصول المساعدات الانسانيه العاجله
الى المناطق المنكوبه ونتائج الكارثه
الطبيعيه واحده على كل الضحايا السوريين
تسابق فرق الانقاذ غير المجهزه بالعتاد
اللازم الزمنه لاخراجنا جينا من تحت
الانقاض وانتشال جثث القتلى عمليه صعبه
وسط ظروف سياسيه ومناخيه غير طبيعيه
لحظه فرح في ايام تراجيديا زلزال مدمر في
سوريا سعاده الطفل وفرق الانقاذ ظرفيه
[تصفيق]
يا عمري
فالماسات طويله وكبيره بكل تفاصيلها
المؤلمه لا تملك فرق الانقاذ ما يكفي من
المعدات لاخراج الناجين وانتشال الجثث
ورفع الانقاذ
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله في بعض المناطق
المتضرره يتولى المواطنون بايديهم عمليات
البحث عن ذويهم وشيرانهم تتاخر المساعدات
الانسانيه الدوليه المطلوبه لاسباب سياسيه
معقده وفي كل تاخير يعاجل الموت من استعصى
انقاذهم سواء تحت الركام او في المستشفيات
الفقيره اصلا بسبب ظروف الحرب
الله يرحمه يودعهم فردا فردا مصابه جلل في
يوم واحد سيدفن خمسه وعشرين من عائلته
الصغيره والكبيره بينهم ابنته واحفاده
من الحرب
على اساس ولاولادنا
سبحان الله القدر لوين
ملايين السوريين نزحوا او لجاوا منذ 2011
هربا من القصف والاشتباكات في مناطق
التماس وكثير منهم استقروا في المدن
التركيه التي دمرها الزلزال القاتل خاصه
في غازي عنتاب وانطاكيا دخل وطنهم او
خارجه الاف منهم اليوم يبتون في الشارع في
الطقس بارد لا يرحم ماما مصيرهم واي مكان
سيؤويهم بعد الان تدهور البنى التحتيه
وغياب الامكانيات يعقد عمليات الانقاذ
المستمره في عتمه الليل ودون اضاءه كافيه
وبلا ادوات حفر متطوره لا يتوقف المسعفون
عن العمل يحدوهم دائما الامل في العثور
على ناجين
حدثت بعض المعجزات منذ كابوس فجر الاثنين
لكنها ضوء خافت وسط صوره مظلمه باعداد
القتلى المرتفعه يوما بعد يوم وبظروف
انتشال الجثث وشبه حياه الناجين جسديا من
الموت الصور من السماء مرعبه وعلى الارض
لكلمه تصف بدقه المصيبه التي حلت
بالسوريين الزلزال سوى بالارض بيوتا
يسكنها ما بقي من صبر على المحن ومن
سوريين يتحملوا الكثير ولاكثر من عقد من
الزمن
البلد يستغيث اكثر من اي وقت مضى لنجدته
من كارثه طبيعيه لم تفرق بين سوريا واخر
ومنطقه واخرى ثمه وطن واحد ابنائه تحت
الركام منذ الاثنين المفجع
في تركيا قال نائب رئيس تركيا ان 61 الف
منقذين من 60 دوله دخلوا البلاد للمساهمه
في عمليات الانقاذ هذا ويتواصل تدفق
المساعدات الانسانيه المحليه والدوليه الى
المناطق المنكوبه التي ضربها الزلزال في
تركيا قوافل مساعدات مؤلفه من مئات
الشاحنات التي تحمل التحمل اليات ثقيله
لرفع الانقاض ومساعدات اخرى ازدحمت على
طريق السريع قونيا اضنه وصف ثلوجا كثيفه
مشكله طابورا امتدا لاكثر من 30 كيلومترا
في طريقها للوصول الى منكوبي الزلزال جنوب
شرقي تركيا
اما الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان الذي
وصف ماتشده البلاد بالكارثه الكبرى فقد
وصل الى المناطق المنكوبه في كهرمان مراش
وهاتاي حيث اكد من هناك ان الدوله تبذل
قصار جهدها لتخفيف اثار الزلزال
نواجهه كارثه كبرى كان الشعب التركي اظهر
صبرا كبيرا في كوارث شبيهه وهو يظهر صبرا
كبيرا على هذه الكارثه ايضا الدوله تبذل
كل ما في وسعها لتخفيف اثار الكارثه ويعمل
الوزراء يدا بيد مع مسؤول المؤسسات
والبلديات
هذا ويتابع اهالي منطقه او مدينه ملاطيا
الجنوبيه تركيا بقلق كبير عمليات البحث عن
العالقين تحت ركام المباني التي انهارت
جراء الزلزال العنيف الذي ضرب البلاد
وانهار نحو ثلاثمائه مبنى بالمدينه بينما
زاد عدد الضحايا عن 170 شخصا مراسلتنا
سلام خضر تابعت عمليات الانقاذ واعدت
التقرير التالي
بحثا عن الامل يتمسك العم عرفان بالبقاء
هنا والامل حفيدتان لا تزالان تحت الانقاض
لقد انتشلوا ابني وولديه وننتظر خبرا عن
ابنتيه ليس بيدنا شيء سوى الانتظار
العمل في الموقع يسير بتانن خشيه مزيد من
الانهيارات بين الحين والاخر يتقدم احد
افراد فرق البحث والانقاذ لتقديم معلومات
للعائلات
يسرع العم احمد الخطى عله يحظى باي خبر عن
ابنه
قريبتي مع ثلاثه من اطفالها عالقون في
الطابق الثالث نشعر بالتوتر فمع مرور
الوقت تصبح عمليه الانقاذ معقده
هذا المبنى انهار في الزلزال الاول ومن
نجا من العائلات لم يغادر المكان
النساء يغالبنا دموعه النحينا
ويكتفين بالدعاء دوما ان لطفا بالمفقودين
انتشل اخي وابنه من تحت الانقاض ويبحثون
عن بناتها الثلاث
وفجاه يتوقف كل شيء
لا شيء سوى الصمت
هنا لم يصلوا الى نتيجه بعد لكن في موقع
قريب الوضع اكثر قسوه انتشال ضحيه جديده
يقدر عدد الضحايا في المدينه حتى الان
بنحو 170 والاعداد مرشحه للارتفاع انهار
اكثر من 300 مبنى سكني وتجاري بشكل كامل
في مالاتيا تتشابه مشاهد الدمار في المدن
المنكوبه وحيث ما وليت وجهك تقابلك قصص
تفيض الما وحزنا قصص تختلف في تفاصيلها
لكن المشترك بينها
هو التعلق بامل
محاصر تحت الانقاض سلام خضر الجزيره
جنوب تركيا
ينضم الينا من اسطنبول دورموش ايدينا
الامين العام لهيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه سيد
اديب مرحبا بك معنا كيف تقيم عمليات
الاغاثه والانقاذ حتى الساعه
شكرا جزيلا لاستضافه
نحن الان تقريبا
انهينا
ساعه بعد اربع ساعات من الان في الهزات
الارضيه الساعات 72 الاولى هي الاهم
النافع المحافظات التسعه بعض فرق نقاط
تقوم بهذه جهود كبيره لانقاذ حياه الناس
واخراجهم من تحت الركام هذه اوقات اصيبه
بالنسبه للناس
ايضا يعانون ويتحدثون بسبب
رداءه الجو نحن لن نفقد الامل ولم نفقده
لان نشاهد مرات كثيره في في ظروف كثيره
وفي الدول كثيره في مناطق الكوارث وشاهدنا
انه حتى بعد خمس ايام سبع دقائق وجدنا
اناس على قيد الحياه
حاليا تعمل على الارض وهي ابحث عن الناس
وسيلهون برنامجهم بعد ان يجدوا اخر تحت
الارقام
الى اذاعه مفيده وصول فرق الانقاذ
والاغاثه من الدول التي قامت بذلك خاصه في
مثل هذه الساعات الحاسمه الثلاث ايام
الاولى
فرق البحث والانقاذ من دول مختلفه هناك 77
الدوله عرضت تقديم فرقها وارسالها والكثير
من هذه الدول فعلا وصلوا وصلت هذه الفرق
الى تركيا وهذا مهم جدا لان نظرنا الى حجم
الهلسه الارضيه كان كبيرا جدا ومنتشره على
مساحه واسعه وبالتالي نحن بحتى حاجه
الكثير من فرق البحثي والانقاذ في لدينا
الكثير من الفرق الانقاذ والبحث ولكن ايضا
في الوقت ذاته فان المنظمات الدوليه
والدول الخارجيه
فراقها سيكون ذلك مفيدا جدا لانقاذ حياه
البشر وامر حاسما لاننا نتحدث ليس عن 100
بيت او او بالف بيت عندما نتحدث عن الاف
المنازل والمباني قد انهارت وبالتالي
يحتاجون الكثير من فرق البحث والانقاذ
حاليا ماذا عن المعدات التي تحتاجونها
ايضا
تركيا لديها العديد منها وهي تقوم الان
بهذه العمليات وشاهدنا طريقا وطابورا
طويلا من هذه المعدات التي تتجه نحو
المناطق المنكوبه
نعم نعم انك محقه هذه المعدات فعل حاسمه
ومهمه جدا ان المعدات والمكائن هي تعتبر
العناصر الرئيسيه للمساعده في وقت الهزات
الارضيه لان ركام المباني لا يمكن ازالته
بالعيد نحتاج هذه المكان وعدادات لمساعده
فرق البحث والانقاذ وبالتالي لذلك الحكومه
والدول اسست الكثير من المعدات لهذه الفرق
لتساعدهم في عمليه البحث وتسجيل عملي وهذا
فعلا تحسن كثيرا
كيف تجري عمليه توزيع فرق الدعم والانقاذ
على تلك المدن المنكوبه
نعم ان هذا فعلا واحد من اشياء الصعبه
حاليا لانه عندما حصل في هذه الارضيه
الكثير من الجسور والطرق انهارت وبالتالي
فن التجهيزات مواد الانقاذ تتطلب وقتا
طويله للوصول الى المنكوبه والان وزاره
المباني والطرق تقوم باقامه فعلا باصلاح
الدستور والطرق واصبح الان اسهل بالنسبه
لايصال هذه المعدات الى المدن
كان الامر صعبا جدا اما الان فقد فتحت كل
الطرق وبالتالي يمكن لهذه المعدات
والمسائل تصل الى المدن ولكن بسبب الجو
البارد جدا والناس في الشوارع يحاولون
يعيشوا تحت الخيام وما زالوا يحاولوا ان
يحصلوا على ماوى في مدارس او اي مكان
والاشخاص يحتاجون الى الغذاء الساخن يحتاج
الى البطانيات والى مواد اخرى اذا هذه هي
حالات
الرئيسيه الاولى التي يحتاجونها وايضا
هناك مساله اهميه تقديم الدعم النفسي
والاجتماعي لهؤلاء الناس الذين هم اعداد
وصلت بالملايين من الناس في الواقع فهذه
المنطقه
13 مليون شخصا تاثروا بهذه الذات الارضيه
وكل هؤلاء الناس بالتالي يحتاجون الى
مساعدات بشكل كبير شكرا لك من اسطنبول
درموش ايدين الامين العام لهيئه الاغاثه
الانسانيه شكرا على المشاركه معنا
في اخبارنا الاخرى من العالم اعلنت رئاسه
الفرنسيه ان الرئيس ايمانويل ماكرون يعقد
مساء اليوم في باريس لقاء مع كل من الرئيس
الاوكراني فلودي والمستشار الالماني
وكان رئيس الاوكراني
في وقت سابق اليوم في لندن مع رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني
وفي مؤتمر صحفي مشترك قال سوناك ان
بريطانيا مستعده لمناقشه كل شيء حين يتعلق
الامر بدعم اوكرانيا عسكريا في اشاره الى
قضيه ارسال طائرات مقاتله الى كيف من
جهتها نقلت وكاله رويترز عن الرئيس
الاوكراني قوله ان الرئيس الوزراء
البريطاني عبر عن رغبته في ان يكون قادرا
على دعم اوكرانيا بمقاتلات
اعلنت بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في ليبيا
اعتمادا اللجنه العسكريه المشتركه 5 + 5
بحضور لجنه التواصل الليبيه ونظيرتها من
النيجر والسودان في القاهره اليه متكامله
للتنسيق المشترك في جمع وتبادل البيانات
بشان المرتزقه والمقاتلين الاجانب
ما بعد الزلزال جهود مستمره في سوريا
لانقاذ العالقين والبحث عن ناجين تحت
الانقاض اعداد الضحايا تقارب الثلاثه الاف
قتيل واكثر من خمسه الاف مصاب والدفاع
المدني يحذر من ارتفاع مضطرد في عدد
الوفيات شمال غربي البلاد بسبب قله
الامكانات
وعلى وقع الماساه الامم المتحده تقول ان
مساعداتها تنتظر دخول مناطق شمال غرب
سوريا وتدعو الى تحييد السياسه منسقها
الاقليمي يقول للجزيره انه يامل دخولها
غدا ووزير الخارجيه التركي يؤكد العمل على
فتح معبرين اضافيين والمفوضيه الاوروبيه
تتحدث عن مؤتمر للمانحين
وفي تركيا ضحايا الزلزال يقتربون من عتبه
العشره الاف قتيل واكثر من خمسين الف جريح
الرئيس التركي يصف ما تواجهه البلاد
بالكارثه الكبرى والسلطات تعلن وصول فرق
انقاذ من 60 دوله
[موسيقى]
تتصاعد ارقام ضحايا كل ساعه ومعها اعداد
المصابين المنتشرين احياء الوضع في
المناطق السوريه المنكوبه بالزلزال هو
الاسوا حيث الزلزال والبرد وانعدام دخول
المساعدات ومعدات الانقاذ حتى الان ارتفع
عدد القتل في سوريا الى اكثر من
2900 وفي سباق مع الزمن يعمل متطوع الدفاع
المدني السوري او فرق الخوذ البيضاء في
مناطق سيطره المعارضه لانتشال ناجين من
تحت الانقاض وتتناقص امالهم باعتبار
الايام الثلاثه الاولى التي تنقضي بعد
سويعات اعتبارها حاسمه كي لا يفقد الاحياء
المطمرون بالان حياتهم كما اكد ذلك نائب
مدير الدفاع المدني منير مصطفى في نشره
سابقه للجزيره
بدانا نفقد الامر حقيقه نحن نتجاوز ساعات
العمل ستين ساعه
المصابين تحت الانقراض ذاته عرضه الى ان
يفقدوا ارواحهم جراء عدم وصول فرق القوات
البيضاء اليهم وذلك نتيجه نقص المعدات
التي ناشدنا كل الدول ناشدنا الامم
المتحده ناشدنا الاتحاد الاوروبي ناشدنا
كل الدول حول العالم ان ترسل لنا هذه
المعدات لم تصل اي مساعده حقيقيه انا لا
اعرف لماذا الانسانيه لماذا الانسانيه
لماذا الوضع الانساني دائما يحسب على
الشعب السوري من الناحيه السياسيه وينزل
عليه من الناحيه السياسيه
هذا كان عن سوريا اما في تركيا فقد بلغت
الهزات الارتداديه منذ زلزال الاثنين بلغت
790 هزه وفق نائب الرئيس التركي كما ارتفع
عدد القتلى الى تسعه الاف
وسبعه وخمسين وناهز عدد الجرحى 53 الفا
واحصي من المباني المنهاره سته الاف واربع
مئه واربعه واربعون وتواصلت جهود الانقاذ
ومسابقه الساعات الاخيره من اليوم الثالث
لانتشال من بقي حيا تحت الانقاض حيث تجاوز
عدد العاملين في الفرق الميدانيه الصحيه
والامنيه والانقاذ الحكوميه 100 الف شخص
تبقى لحظات وانتشال الاحياء من تحت
الانقاض هي بواعث الامل النادره وسط الوضع
الماساويه الذي تزامن فيه الزلزال مع حاله
طقس سيء تدنت فيه الحراره لما دون السفر
الا ان فرق فرحه المنقذين بانتشال ناج
واحد رغم الاف الوفيات تعطي المشهد ابعادا
انسانيه خاصه لنتابع
تمكنت فرق الانقاذ في مدينه غازي عنتاب
تركيا من انقاذ طفل بعمر سبع سنوات من تحت
الانقاض بعد مرور 55 ساعه على الزلزال
الذي ضرب جنوبي البلاد
نذهب لمراسلين من اعزاز في ريف حلب معنا
محمد الجزائري ومن غازي عنتاب مراسلنا
منتصر ابونا معك محمد الجزائري اذا كيف
تبدو عمليات الانقاذ في منطقه اعزاز ريف
حلب بشكل عام وايضا عمليات
اغاثه واجلاء النازحين
نعم سمعنا في الحقيقه عمليات
الاغاثه هي تتركز هنا في هذه المدن ان كان
مدينه عزاز او مدينه عفرين وبعض المدن
الاخرى التي انشات نقاط لاستقبال وايواء
هذه النقاط والهواء
المؤقته للذين تضرروا جراء هذا الزلزال
وفقدوا منازلهم وفقدوا ممتلكاتهم بالاضافه
الى ان مناظرهم لم تعد صالحه للسكان تصدعت
منازلهم هذه الفرق التطوعيه التي تعمل على
هذه هذه النقاط وانشاء هذه النقاط هنا في
مدينه عزاز المدينه التي لم تتضرر بشكل
كبير او كانت اضرار محدوده فيها جراء هذا
الزلزال انشئت انشاوا هؤلاء المتطوعون
اكثر من 15 نقطه لاستقبال وايواء النازحين
هذه النقطه التي نحن فيها نحن فيها
كل خيمه داخلها ثلاث او اربع او خمسه
عائلات تقطن فيها الى ان يتم نقلها الى
مخيمات يتم انشاءها حديثا للمتضرين جراء
الزلزال او هي مخيمات اخرى يخرجون للسكن
مع اقاربهم او انشاء قيام جديده ليقيمون
فيها بشكل مؤقت او بشكل مستمر هؤلاء الفرق
التطوعيه حقيقه يعملون
بتنظيم وكشبكه في كامل المدينه بالتنسيق
مع الجهات المحليه فرق تكون عندما داخل
المدينه كل ما رات احد من الاهالي
المتضررين يدخلون الى المدينه تاخذهم
وتوجههم الى النقاط التي يمكن الاستيعاب
اعداد فيها يتم استيعابهم فيها تقديم لهم
ما امكن من التبرعات التي جمعوها من البسه
واغطيه يقيمون في هذه القيام يقدمون لهم
التدفئه وبعض الوجبات الاغا في الغذائيه
المقدمه من المنظمات الانسانيه يقومون
بتنظيم عمل المنظمات الانسانيه والمساعدات
مقدمه من المنظمات المحليه هنا في المنطقه
لان
لا يكون هناك
ضياع للجهود بشكل كامل يحاول تنظيم الجهود
بشكل كامل هذه النقاط ايضا في هناك مثلها
في مدينه عفرين تتركز كل النقاط في هذه
المدينتين اتصالات او في الحدائق العامه
او في صالات الرياضيه في المساجد بعض
المساجد في الجامعات يستغلون كل المناطق
المفتوحه والتي يمكن انشاء خيام فيها او
استقبال اعداد فيها اللي هي
الاستثمارها بشكل كبير حتى الان هذه
المدينه استقبلت حوالي 4000 عائله من
المتضررين شراء الزلزال ان كان من مدينه
جنديرس او من مدينه الاتارب او حتى من
مدينه سرمدا التي تبعد عن هذا من هنا اكثر
من 70 او 75 كيلو مترا
الاهالي يبحثون عن مناطق اكثر امنا او
يجنون فيها شيئا من الامان حقيقه هذه هنا
هنا هذه القيام وهذه النقاط هي بدايه
ماساه الا ربما لهؤلاء الاهالي عندما
يستيقظون من الصدمه الذي شاهدوها خلال هذا
الزلزال وهذه الكارثه سيشاهدون انفسهم بلا
ممتلكاتهم التي بقيت تحت انقاض المنازل
بعضهم فقد المنازل وفقد ممتلكاتهم وباتوا
عادوا من نقطه السفر في حياتهم فهنا ستكون
جديده في حياتهم سيذهبون لربما الى القيام
التي هي تعاني اساسا من الاوضاع الانسانيه
الصعبه من نقص المساعدات من نقص التمويل
والنقص الخدمات المتواجده في هذه الخيام
ستبدا معاناه جديده لهم وهذا ما يتخوف منه
الكثير من الاهالي اما من جانب اخر وهو من
عمليات البحث والانقاذ اما زالت مستمره في
مدينه جنديرس يوم اليوم صباحا دخل فريق من
فريق مصري من دوله مصر عبر الحدود من
تركيا الى مدينه جنديرس وهو فريق مؤلف من
فريق تقني وفريق طبي بحسب ما قال نائب
مدير الدفاع المدني ان هذا الفريق هذا
الفريق سيساعد في البحث
وزياده فرص في البحث عن ناجين او مفقودين
تحت
الدمار في المنطقه
الاكثر تضررا في الشمال شكرا لك ومنتصر
ابو نبود كيف تبدو الصوره وانت في غازي
عنتاب
نعم انا الان في وسط مدينه غازي عنتاب
حقيقه هناك يعني ثوابت عديده منذ هز هذا
الزلزال مدينه غازي عنتاب هنالك سكان من
مدينه غازي عنتاب نزلوا الى الشوارع والى
ساحات العامه وهم يفترشون العرب ومنهم من
قد حصل على قيام بالفعل اليوم بدات عمليه
نصب القيم ومنهم من يقيم في سيارته في
مكان يعني يكون واسع بعيد عن الابنيه
العاليه وايضا هنالك عمليه بحث مستمره تحت
الانقاط المواقع التي تهجمت وفي المباني
التي ردت على رؤوس ساكنيها وعمليات البحث
مستمره ولو ان يعني طول الوقت في هذا
البحث قد يعني يفقد الامل لخروج ناجين من
تحت الانقاذ ايضا هنالك حركه جويه مستمره
قبل قليل كنا نسمع صوت الطائرات طائرات
الشحن التي تاتي الى مطار غازي عنتاب
وتحمل المساعدات ضمن الجسر الجوي الذي دشن
والذي على اعلن عنه وزير الدفاع التركي
ويتم ايضا نقل المساعدات من مطار غازي
عنتاب الى مدينه غازي عنتاب وايضا الى
المدن المنكوبه في جنوب تركيا لان
المطارات هناك ليس لا تعمل بشكل مناسب
لانها تضررت بسبب هذا الزلزال ايضا
السيارات الاسعاف نشاهدها بين الفتره
والاخرى وهي يعني مسرعه وتنقل من يعني تم
انتشالهم من تحت الانقاذ لا يتسن لنا
معرفه اذا كان الذين
يسعفونهم يعني جرحى ام انهم قد لقوا حتفهم
في هذا
يعني في في هذا الحادث نحن الان نقف
بالقرب من احد المشافي التي يعني استقبلت
من من الجرحى الذين او من الاشخاص الذين
تم انتشالهم من تحت الانقاذ هذا المشفى
نشاهد الان هذه سياره اسعاف كانت قد دخلت
قبل قليل مس الان هي تخرج من المشفى
وعلى ما يبدو انها تتوجه الى مكان اخر
ايضا هنا بالقرب من هذا المشفى يوجد مشفى
اخر هذا هو هذا مشفى موجود ايضا بالقرب
منه ايضا كان قد استقبل من الاشخاص الذين
انتشروا من تحت الانقاذ ايضا شاهدنا
الاعلام علامه التركيه قد نكثت حدادا على
حدادا على
الاشخاص الذين
شكرا لك غازي عنتاب منتصر ابو نبوت ومحمد
الجزائري من عزاز
تجد فرق الانقاذ نفسها في سباق مع الزمان
للوصول الى اكبر عدد من الناجين باعتبار
عامل الوقت حاسما وتتضائل مع مروره فرص
انقاذ عالقين تحت الانقاض ويبقى تحديد
موعد لوقف عمليات الانقاذ بدوره حساسا
وصعبا ويخضع لظروف وعوامل عديده نستعرض
معركه البحث والانقاذ وما يحدد خياراتها
مع الزلزال الذي ضرب جنوبي تركيا وشماليه
سوريا في هذا التقرير
قبل 13 عاما عاشت هايتي زلزالا مدمرا
تجاوز 7 درجات على سلم ريختر واودى بحياه
نحو 200 الف شخص وشرد نحو مليونين وبعد
تسعه ايام اعلنت الحكومه الهايتيه انتهاء
مرحله البحث والانقاذ مع تضاؤل فرص العثور
على المزيد من الاشخاص على قيد الحياه قله
من الاشخاص المحاصرين يمكنهم البقاء على
قيد الحياه لمده طويله خلال الزلازل واول
اثنتين وسبعين ساعه تعد حرجه لانها توفر
اعلى فرص لوجودنا جيم لكن يتعين على اجهزه
التنسيق في البلد المتضرر اتخاذ القرار
الصعب بشان متى تتوقف عن البحث عن الاشخاص
المحاصرين المتبقين تحت الانقاض متوسط
الوقت لذلك عاده ما يرابح بين خمسه ايام
وسبعه ويعتمد على عوامل مثل الطقس والهزه
الارتداديه ومدى سرعه وصول فرق الانقاذ
والمعدات لكن تقديره خبراء في الزلازل
تشير الى ان الافراد يظلون على قيد الحياه
لمده تصل الى 13 يوما اذا كان لديهم
امكانيه الوصول الى الماء واكثر من ذلك
اذا ما وفر لهم الطعام العامل الاكثر
الحاحا هو الحصول على رعايه الطبيه
للاشخاص تحت المباني المنهره قبل انهيار
اجسادهم او نسفهم وفضل لحاله الطقس
الحاليه يعد انخفاض درجه حراره الجسم امرا
ممكنا وربما يموت الناس للاسف بسبب ذلك
وبدون ماء قد يفقد الكثير منهم حياتهم
تلتزم بعض فرق الانقاذ الدوليه ما يعرف
بقاعده الاربعه وتفترض بقاء المحاصرين تحت
الانقاض على قيد الحياه لمده اربع دقائق
دون هواء واربعه ايام دون ماء واربعه
اسابيع دون طعام وتتحدث عن 48 ساعه ذهبيه
يبقى القول ان وقف عمليه الانقاذ قرار صعب
الا انه بالمقابل يسمح بتركيز الموارد على
رعايه الالاف من الناجين الاخرين وع
التعافي والمساعده في ازاله الانقاض لهذا
ووفق بروتوكولات دوليه معتمده يجب ان يكون
عمال الانقاذ سريعين لتقييم الاماكن التي
من المرجح ان يجدوا فيها ناجين داخل
المباني المنهاره ويمكن الاستفاده من
كاميرات الفيديو عبر الفجوات الموجوده في
الانقاض ومعدات التصوير الحراري لتحديد
اماكن الناجين ويمكن لمعدات الصوت
المتخصصه اكتشاف اضعف الاصوات في نطاق
امتار قليله وتعد الكلاب المدربه فعاله
للغايه باستخدام حاسه الشم في كشف ناجين
ناهيك بتعاون المجتمعات المحليه في تحديد
الاماكن ويمكن ايضا استخدام اجهزه الكشف
عن ثاني اكسيد الكربون للعثور على الناجين
الذين فقدوا الوعي حيث يكتشف المنقذون
تركيزه في الهواء عند نفسه ممن ما زالوا
يتنفسون
[موسيقى]
في ظل هذه الظروف ناشده منسق الامم
المتحده الاقليميه لشؤون الانسانيه للازمه
السوريه مهند هادي الدول المانحه لتقديم
المساعدات للمنكوبين من الزلزال في سوريا
واضاف هذه في مقابله على الجزيره ان الشعب
السوري عانى من ويلات الحرب على مدى سنوات
طويله وجاء زلزال ليفاقم معاناه وهو بحاجه
لاي مساعده ممكنه
كما عرب المنسق الاممي للشؤون الانسانيه
في سوريا مهند هادي في مقابلته على
الجزيره عن امله في ان تتمكن اولى شاحنات
المساعدات من العبور يوم غدا الخميس الى
داخل الاراضي السوريه من خلال معبر باب
الهوى
في معوقات لوجستيه كثيره الطرق جزء منها
كبير قد قد تضرر
واصبحت غير يعني اصبحت امكانيه وصول
الشاحنات صعبه لكن المعلومات اللي وصلتنا
بعد ظهر اليوم انه اصبحت الطريق الان
سالكه الى حد ما طبعا مشتركه بالطريقه
اللي كانت قبل قبل الزلزال لكن ممكن انها
شاحنات تصل الى الحدود وطبعا في الشاحنات
اللي بدها تيجي من المناطق السوريه ليتم
تبديل المواد من من الشاحنات التركيه الى
الشاحنات السوريه نامل وكلنا امل انه بكره
نستطيع انه
نتمم موضوع النقل المساعدات عبر الحدود
وكان المصطفى بن المليحه المنسق الانسانيه
المؤقت للامم المتحده في سوريا قال ان
الزلزاله فاقم من معاناه ملايين السوريين
واوضح المصطفى بن مليحه في احاطه صحفيه
عبر تقنيه الفيديو انه حتى قبل الزلزال
كانت البنيه التحتيه المتعلقه بطرق
والمياه والكهرباء والوقود سيئه للغايه
والان اصبحت اسوا وهذا يؤثر على العمل
الانساني ودع المناسق الانساني المؤقت
للامم المتحده في سوريا الى وضع
الاعتبارات السياسيه جانبا والعمل على
البعد الانساني
وفي مقابله مع الجزيره ايضا قالت مديره
مستشفى الامومه في ادلب اكرام حبوش ان
عددا من المشافي خرجوا عن الخدمه ما فاقم
المعاناه القائمه اصلا في الشمال الغربي
لسوريا واضافت ان شيئا من المساعدات او
فرق الانقاذ لم يدخل بعد من المعابر الى
الداخل السوري
نحن بالاصل عم نعاني من نقص شديد
بالامكانيات والتراجع في الدعم في القطاع
الصحي في شمال غرب سوريا وخاصه بعد ازمه
اوكرانيا هلا انا
كقطاع نسائيه وتوليد بسبب انه قسم من
مشافي
تقدم هاي الخدمه طلعت عن العمل مثل المشفى
الامومي في الدانه وباقي المشافي او مشاكل
اخرى فهذا الشيخ اللي عنا ضغط نحن على
المشافي اللي لسه عم نقدم الخدمه ضغط كبير
من ناحيه انه المراجعين باعدادهم الكبير
اللي نحن ما فينا عم نحسن نقدم شيء
عم نحاول قدر الامكان يعني خدمه الولاده
والقيصرين امنهم اياها بس نحن بالنسبه
لالنا قسم الحواضن ممتلئ وقسم حديثي
الولاده الممتلئ بس اذا بدنا نحكي على
المشاكل اللي عم تقدم الجراحات والمشافه
اللي عم يصير عليها اسعاف الجرحى ومصابين
نحن بالاصل بالشمال غير سوريا عدد الاطباء
والمنشات قليل لحد الان المعابر ما دخل
منها ولا فريق انقاذ ولا دخل اي شيء من
المساعدات
ويواجه القطاع الصحي في مناطق الشمال
السوري المنكوبه بالزلزال صعوبه كبيره في
التعامل مع الاعداد الهائله من الاصابات
والحالات الحرجه وتضم المناطق الخاضعه
للسيطره المعارضه في شمال غرب سوريا ما
يزيد على 500 مؤسسه صحيه ظل اغلبها في
الخدمه بالاعتماد على دعم المانحين
الدوليين
261 من تلك المنشاه الطبيه توجد في محافظه
ادلب وتتوزع بين مشاف وعيادات ومراكز
رعايه مختصه لكن تلك المؤسسات الصحيه
جميعها تواجه نقصا في الكادر الطبي بعد ان
غادرها نحو 70% من العاملين فيها بفعل
الحرب بحسب الصليب الاحمر الدولي ما جعل
طبيبا واحدا يخدم نحو عشره الاف شخص من
اصل ما يقرب من اربعه ملايين نسمه وفقا
لتقديرات اداره القطاع الصحي في مناطق
شمال غرب سوريا كما المشافي في تلك
المناطق منذ ما قبل كارثه الزلزال من نقص
حاد في المستلزمات الصحيه الاساسيه
كالاسعافات الاوليه ومواد التخدير وصفائح
المستخدمه لكسور العظام
ومنذ اليوم الاول للزلزال كهرمان مرعش عاد
الى الواجهه الحديث عن دخول او اليه دخول
المساعدات الانسانيه الى سوريا خصوصا في
مناطق الشمال حيث طلبت منظمات دوليه ان
يكون وصول المساعدات دون تقييد حسب وصفها
فتقرير التالي نتعرف على ما بقي من خيارات
يمكن عبرها ادخال المساعدات
بمثل الحاح اقصى ايام الحرب وربما اكثر
تبدو حاجه السوريين الان لمد يد العون
اليهم في كل شيء خصوصا لانقاذ العالقين
تحت ركام المباني التي هدمها زلزال كهرمان
مراش الدفاع المدني السوري في مناطق
المعارضه شمالا اطلق نداءات عاجله طلبا
للمساعده ومثله فعل النظام ومع ان الظرف
الانساني واحد قاهر وعصيب لكن الظروف
السياسيه لكل منطقه من سوريا تفرض نفسها
في هذا الوقت فمناطق المعارضه لديها معبر
واحد يسمح من خلاله بدخول المساعدات
الدوليه بتفويض اممي يجدد كل سته اشهر هو
معبر باب الهوى مع تركيا بعد اصرار الروسي
والنظام السوري على اغلاق معبر باب
السلامه في ريف حلب خلال السنوات الماضيه
اما في مناطق النظام السوري فتكثر
الخيارات البريه منها والجوبيه وهي مطاره
حلب ودمشق اللذان بدا فعلا باستقبال
الشحنات المساعدات المقدمه من دول عربيه
وغيرها اضافه لمعابر بريه مع دول الجوار
بحسب وزي الخارجيه السوري فيصل المقداد
فان العقوبات الامريكيه المفروض على
النظام تفاقم من سوء الاوضاع رغم تاكيد
الجانب الامريكي استثناء المساعدات
الانسانيه من تلك العقوبات وهو نفس
الاستثناء الذي نص عليه قرار مجلس الامن
الاخير بشان وصول المساعدات الى سوريا
ايضا ابدت جهات سوريه ومنها الهلال الاحمر
السوري العامل في مناطق النظام استعدادها
لايصال المساعدات الى كل المناطق حتى
الخارجه عن سيطره الحكومه وفق وصفها وهو
مطلب لطالما اصر النظام السوري ومعه روسيا
على تحقيقه في مجلس الامن اي ان يتولى
النظام السوري وتوزيع المساعدات في مناطقه
ومناطق المعارضه عبر ما يطلق عليها ادخال
المساعدات عبر خطوط التماس وهي اليه تعيب
المعارضه منظمات انسانيه في الشمال السوري
عليها ان النظام لا يوصل عبرها من
المساعدات سوى النزر اليسير كما انه يسعى
من خلالها الى تحقيق مكاسب سياسيه الثابت
ان زلزال كهرمان ماراش ادخل الجميع في
مضمار السباق مع الوقت فمع كل دقيقه تمر
يتكشف الحجم الحقيقي للكارثه سواء في
تركيا او في سوريا
ينضم الينا من غازي عنتاب منذر السلال
مدير وحده الدعم الاستقرار سيد مذر سلال
مرحبا بك معنا اذا هناك وعود بان
المعوقات اللوجستيه من اجل ايصال
المساعدات تم تذليلها وستصل غدا او اليوم
الخميس الى مناطق الشمال السوريه هل هذا
الكلام دقيق
ولن تحياتي لك ولجميع الساده المشاهدين
والرحمه للضحايا في الحقيقه انا الان في
اعزاز وكنت اليوم في في جوله يعني على بعض
المناطق المنكوبه واهمها جنديرس في ريف
عفرين التي يعني فيها دمار كبير جدا
وبحسب شهادات الاهالي انه لو لو كان في
فرق انقاذ موجوده كان اكثر من نصف يعني
القتلى يعني كان ممكن انقاذهم
الكارثه كبيره جدا لا يوجد يعني خلال
الثلاث ايام الماضيه اي مساعدات لا على
الصعيد الخاص بالكارثه التي نحن بها كانت
الزلزال ولا حتى على الصعيد السابق يعني
المساعدات التي كانت تصل تباعا وتكرارا
يعني
سابقا طبعا هنالك موانع اللوجستيه في
تقريركم ولكن نحن اليوم يعني نعاني من
كارثه انسانيه لا يمكن يعني
التعذر فقط بالموانع اللوجستيه يعني سابقا
انا اذكر
عندما يعني كنا محاصرين من قبل داعش كانت
يعني احيانا تنزل المساعدات عبر الطائرات
مساعدات انسانيه نحن اليوم في كارثه كبيره
جدا ونترقم المساعدات يعني في الداخل
السوري اليوم هنالك مساعدات من الاهالي من
بعضهم البعض هنالك قوافل بشكل دائم من
يعني من المدن تساعد بعضها البعض ولكن
اليوم تبحثين عن خيمه
لكي يعني فقط تشتريها وتعطيها
الجزيره بان يعني المساعدات ستصل غدا لان
الطرق جرى اصلاحها وباتت صالحه لمرور
المساعدات هل هذا ما شاهدته اليوم في
طريقك الى عزاز
هلا في يعني هو يعني الواقع انه الطريق
الذي يتحدث عنه المنسق هو الطريق
الريحانيه يعني داخل الاراضي التركيه انا
دخلت الى سوريا من
طريق كلس عزاز
ولكن بالواقع بالتاكيد يعني الريحانيه
وانطاكيا يعني فيها نسبه دمار كبيره ويعني
والرحمه اللي جميع من قضوا هنالك ولكن
يعني هي المنطقه الاكثر تضررا في تركيا
اكيد هنالك موانع اللوجستيه ولكن كان من
الممكن تجاوز هذه الموانع اللوجستيه يعني
كان من الممكن الاستعاضه عن عبر باب الهوى
بمعبر باب السلامه او معبر الراعي او حتى
معبر جرابلس او حتى كذلك هنالك معبر في
عفرين
ممكن استخدامه خاصه نحن نتحدث عن كارثه
انسانيه يعني لا تحتاج الى هذه التعقيدات
انه السماح من مجلس الامن الدولي او حصرا
عبر باب الهوى لانه بالفعل هذه الكارثه
الانسانيه اليوم الاف من الناس هم بالعراء
في جو بارد جدا
يعني هو الابرد خلال خلال فصل الشتاء في
الايام الماضيه
وسمعنا الكثير سمعنا الكثير من الدول يعني
تقول انها جاهزه للمساعده وستقدم المساعده
ولكن
المساعدات يعني تذهب الى الى مناطق النظام
ولكن الى الان لم نرى شيء وصل الى الى
مناطق شمال غرب سوريا اليوم وصل يعني وصل
الى الى شمال غرب سوريا خمس
المصريين دخلوا عبر معبر باب الهوى ولكن
بدون معداته بدون مساعدات دخل وفد من
الحكومه القطريه كذلك عبر المعبر باب
السلامه كذلك بدون مساعدات وبدون معدات
يعني تاخير بايصال المساعدات او المعدات
او فرق تساعد على على الانقاذ هذا يؤدي
الى يعني وفيات وفيات اكثر هذا يؤدي الى
يعني استمرار معاناه معاناه اكبر خاصه ان
هذه
هل لديكم معلومات عن نوع المساعدات التي
جرى تسييرها
ويقال بانها ستصل اليوم الخميس
بتوقعات وتقديرات الامم المتحده الى
المناطق المنكوبه في الشمال السوري
الصراحه لا يوجد يعني توقعات ولكن
يعني نسمع من خلالكم ومن بعض المنظمات انه
المساعدات سوف تاتي
نسال يعني ما هي المساعدات المطلوبه وما
هي اهم الاولويات المطلوبه حاليا
وبالفعل ما نقوم بابلاغهم به انه اهم
المساعدات هي يعني خيم
للمتضررين والذين تهدمت بيوتهم يعني
اسفنجات وكذلك حرامات او بطانيات يعني
يعني وسبل التدفئه هذه اهم اهم الاشياء
التي يعني يجب توفيرها خاصه في فصل الشتاء
ما عدا انه حتى الغير يعني الذين منازلهم
غير مهدمه بسبب كثره الارتدادات يعني
الهزات الارتداديه الناس يعني جميع الناس
تنام الان في الشوارع او يعني في في عبر
بسياره
اسالك عن نوع ايضا المساعدات التي
طلبتموها وهل وعدتم ايضا بتلبيتها فيما
يخص عمليات الانقاذ من تحت الركام وعمليه
ايضا تدعيم المباني او ما شابه من هذه
المطالب الخاصه
بعمليه البناء
الى الان يعني لم يتم
وعدنا باي يعني باشياء محدده سوى الوعودات
التي سمعناها يعني
من الدول عبر وسائل الاعلام وعبر البيانات
الرسميه انه سوف نساعد يعني
المتضررين وسوف نساعد يعني للاستجابه لهذه
الكارثه
يعني قبل بدء الترميم نحن بحاجه الى
في منازل هي لم تنهار ولكن هي معرضه
للانهيار مع اي هزه اخرى فقبل بدء
بالترميم نحن بحاجه لتقييم هذه المنازل
التي يعني يسكنها الان الناس نحن بحاجه
لجهود كبيره من اجل الترميم نحن بحاجه
كذلك يعني سبل انقاذ الناس او او حتى
ازاله الركام
والانقاض من فوق الناس
يعني اعتقد انها يعني صعبه جدا والدفاع
المدني يقوم بدور كبير ولكن الاليات
المتوفره لديه لا يمكن يعني ان انتفي يعني
بحجم الكارثه المطلوب وما نطالب به وطالبت
به عبر شاشتكم اننا بحاجه لاليه استجابه
طارئه دائمه في سوريا
نظرا لتكرار الكوارث التي تحصل يعني في في
سوريا بشكل منذر
مدير وحده دعم الاستقرار حدثنا شكرا جزيلا
لك
تتعاظم ماساه الزلزال الذي ضرب مناطق
سوريه تعاني اصلا من ويلات الحرب
والتداعياتها القاسيه تتعدد الاسباب التي
تجعل وصول المساعدات الانسانيه العاجله
الى المناطق المنكوبه ونتائج الكارثه
الطبيعيه واحده على كل الضحايا السوريين
تسابق فرق الانقاذ غير المجهزه بالعتاده
اللازم الزمن لاخراج ناجينا من تحت
الانقاض وانتشالي جثث القتلى عمليه صعبه
وسط ظروف سياسيه ومناخيه غير طبيعيه
لحظه فرح في ايام تراجيديا زلزال مدمر في
سوريا سعاده الطفل وفرق الانقاذ ظرفيه
[تصفيق]
يا عمري
في الماساه طويله وكبيره بكل تفاصيلها
المؤلمه لا تملك فرق الانقاذ ما يكفي من
المعدات لاخراج الناجين وانتشال الجثث
ورفع الانقاض حتى
ما شاء الله ما شاء الله في بعض المناطق
المتضرره يتولى المواطنون بايديهم عمليات
البحث عن ذويهم وشيرانهم تتاخر المساعدات
الانسانيه الدوليه المطلوبه لاسباب سياسيه
معقده وفي كل تاخير يعاجل الموت من استعصى
انقاذهم سواء تحت الركام او في المستشفيات
الفقيره اصلا بسبب ظروف الحرب
الله يرحمه يودعهم فردا فردا مصابه جلل في
يوم واحد سيدفن خمسه وعشرين من عائلته
الصغيره والكبيره بينهم ابنته واحفاده
ربنا من الحرب
على اساس لاولادنا
سبحان الله القدر
ملايين السوريين نزحوا او لجاوا منذ 2011
هربا من القصف والاشتباكات في مناطق
التماس وكثير منهم استقروا في المدن
التركيه التي دمرها الزلزال القاتل خاصه
في غازي عنتاب وانطاكيا دخل وطنهم او
خارجه الاف منهم اليوم يبتون في الشارع في
طقس بارد لا يرحم ماما مصيرهم واي مكان
سيؤويهم بعد الان تدهور البنى التحتيه
وغياب الامكانيات يعقد عمليات الانقاذ
المستمره في عتمه الليل ودون اضاءه كافيه
وبلا ادوات حفر متطوره لا يتوقف المسعفون
عن العمل يحدوهم دائما الامل في العثور
على ناجين
حدثت بعض المعجزات منذ كابوس فجر الاثنين
لكنها ضوء خافت وسط صوره مظلمه باعداد
القتلى المرتفعه يوما بعد يوم وبظروف
انتشال الجثث وشبه حياه الناجين جسديا من
الموت الصور من السماء مرعبه وعلى الارض
لكلمه تصف بدقه المصيبه التي حلت
بالسوريين الزلزال سوى بالارض بيوتا
يسكنها ما بقي من صبر على المحن ومن
سوريين يتحملوا الكثير ولاكثر من عقد من
الزمن
البلد يستغيث اكثر من اي وقت مضى لنجدته
من كارثه طبيعيه لم تفرق بين سوريا واخر
ومنطقه واخرى ثمه وطن واحد ابنائه تحت
الركام منذ الاثنين المفجع
الينا من كاليفورنيا توماس المدير
التنفيذي لمنظمات دايركت ريلي مرحبا بك
معنا
ازمه سوريا ومعاناتها هي معاناه مركبه جاء
الزلزال يضيف اليها خاصه في مناطق الشمال
السوري هل من امكانيه
للاحاطه بتداعياتها
انكم حقونا حقيقه انه حقيقه ماساه ضعفت
وفاقمت اخرى فالذين كانوا في وضع ضعيف يهش
منذ سنوات يعانون اكثر الان نعم هناك طرق
لمساعدتهم فقط في بسبب ظهوري وانتشار مرض
الكوليرا في الشهر الماضي بعض المنظمات
التي كانت هناك بضمنها
الجمعيه الطبيه السوريه الامريكيه نحن على
اتصال معهم ومنذ ثلاثه ايام منذ وقوع هذه
الزلازل نحاول مساعدتهم على توسيع نطاق
عمليات لانقاذ من يمكن انقاضه
وعلاجه من اصيب
بعلاج طبعا وكلنا يشعر بالاسى لمن فقدوا
حياتهم في هذه الكارثه عمليه دخول
المساعدات لمنطقه الشمال السوري محكومه
بالي توضع ضمن توافقات سياسيه داخل مجلس
الامن هل بالامكان تغيير مثل هذه الاليات
ضمن ظروف خاصه جدا كظرف الزلزال
هناك دائما امكانيه
لايجاد استثناءات مؤسسه
وواضح ان هناك نوايا واضحه ودائما نكشف عن
كل المواد التي
نرصيلها لهذا السبب من الاهميه بمكان لنا
ايضا ان نحترم كل السلطات الفاعله على
الارض سوريا كما تعلمون لها تعقيداتها
الخاصه بها والعمل مع جمعيه الطبيه
السوريه الامريكيه التي تنشط داخل سوريا
منذ اكثر من 10 سنوات ساعد في ظل هذه
الظروف لان الاجنده هنا اجنده انسانيه
وليست سياسيه وايضا في هذه الظروف الشتاء
القارص نحن من جانبنا نحترم الجميع ونحن
التقديم المساعده ونطلب المساعده من
شركائنا في تركيا وفي سوريا ونفعل كل ذلك
مع فهم وادراك لتعقيدات الوضع على الارض
سيتم النداءات والمناشدات سمعناها من قبل
من هم مسؤولون ضمن مجموعات كثيره الدفاع
المدني السوري والبيضاء والمنظمات
الاغاثيه عبر شاشتنا هم يطالبون يعني
قائمه طويله من المساعدات خاصه في هذه
الساعات الحاسمه الى اي درجه تنظرون الى
اهميه ادخالها خاصه في ساعات حاسمه في
حياه من هم تحت الانقاض
نعم السؤال وجيه للغايه واعتقد ان تسلسل
الاحداث في مثل هذه الحالات تولي الاولويه
في الايام الثلاثه الخمسه الاولى الى
انقاذ من هم عالقون تحت الانقاظ لهذا
السبب هذه هي الاولويه الان وفي خلفيه
المسجد هناك ايضا حشد الخدمات الطبيه
الذين هم في حاجه لتقديم المساعده والعلاج
للمصابين هم ايضا يحتاجون ان يكونوا
اولويه لانهم
في وضع حارته الفرق الطبيه يجب ان تعامل
معامله خاصه لانهم هم القادرون على انقاذ
حياه الناس لهذا السبب نحن في تركيا نقدم
الدعم لفرق
الانقاذ والبحث التركيه من المتطوعين
والذين هم في سوريا ايضا يستحقون ان
الاولويه لانهم مع مرور الوقت يصعب انقاذ
من نتاخروا عليهم
بماذا يعني ما نوع المساعدات التي
تمدون بها منطقه الشمال السوري الان
لدينا
تسع عمليات ايصال لطلبات اغافيه تم طلبها
منا نقوم بها اليوم وغدا وهي تتضمن مواد
لمعالجه مرض الكوليا
لعلاج الجرحى وبعض العقاقير والادويه
الاساسيه الذين كانوا يواجهون من تحديات
صحيه قبل الزلزال والان زاد وضعهم صعوبه
طبعا كل ما تتوقعونه من مواد لعلاجه
الالتهابات علاج الكوليرا وايضا علاجي
الامراض المزمنه مثل امراض القلب والسكري
انها تشكيله واسعه من المواد لكن يجب ان
يتم طلبها اولا ثم اتصل الموافق عليها حتى
نستطيع نحن تعبئتها والضمان وصولها بشكل
امن شكرا لك من
المدير التنفيذي لمنظمات دايركت شكرا على
المشاركه معنا
في تركيا قال نائب الرئيس التركي ان واحده
من 60 دوله دخلوا البلاد للمساهمه في
عمليات الانقاذ هذا ويتواصل تدفق
المساعدات الانسانيه المحليه والدوليه الى
المناطق المنكوبه التي ضربها الزلزال في
تركيا هو في المساعدات مؤلفه من مئات
الشاحنات التي تحمل اليات ثقيله لرفع
الانقاض ومساعدات اخرى ازدحمت على طريق
السريع
قونيا اضنه وسط ثلوج كثيفه مشكله طابورا
امتد لاكثر من 30 كيلومترا في طريقها
للوصول الى منكوبي زلزال جنوب شرقي تركيا
اما الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان الذي
وصف ماتشده البلاد بالكارثه الكبرى فقد
وصل الى المناطق المنكوبه في كهرمان مرعش
وهاتاي حيث اكد من هناك ان الدوله تبذل
قصار جودها لتخفيف اثار الزلزال
نواجهه كارثه كبرى كان الشعب التركي اظهر
صبرا كبيرا في كوارث شبيهه وهو يظهر صبرا
كبيرا على هذه الكارثه ايضا الدوله تبذل
كل ما في وسعها لتخفيف اثار الكارثه ويعمل
الوزراء يدا بيد مع مسؤول المؤسسات
والبلديات
يتابع اهالي مدينه ملاطيا جنوبيه تركيا
بقلق كبير عمليات البحث عن العالقين تحت
ركام المباني التي انهارت جراء الزلزال
العنيف الذي ضرب البلاد وانهار نحو 3 مئات
مبنى بالمدينه بينما زاد عدد الضحايا عن
170 شخصا مراسلتنا سلام خضر تابعت عمليات
الانقاذ وعدت تقرير التالي
بحثا عن الامل يتمسك العم عرفان بالبقاء
هنا والامل حفيدتان لا تزالان تحت
الانقاضيف لقد انتشلوا ابني وولديه وننتظر
خبرا عن ابنتيه ليس بيدنا شيء سوى
الانتظار
العمل في الموقع يسير بتانن خشيه مزيد من
الانهيارات بين الحين والاخر يتقدم احد
افراد فرق البحث والانقاذ لتقديم معلومات
للعائلات
يسرع العم احمد الخطى عله يحظى باي خبر عن
ابنه
قريبتي مع ثلاثه من اطفالها عالقون في
الطابق الثالث نشعر بالتوتر فمع مرور
الوقت تصبح عمليه الانقاذ معقده
هذا المبنى انهار في الزلزال الاول ومن
نجا من العائلات لم يغادر المكان
النساء يغالبنا دموعهن حينا
ويكتفين بالدعاء دوما ان لطفا بالمفقودين
انتشل اخي وابنه من تحت الانقاض ويبحثون
عن بناتها الثلاث
وفجاه يتوقف كل شيء
لا شيء سوى الصمت
هنا لم يصلوا الى نتيجه بعد لكن في موقع
قريب الوضع اكثر قسوه انتشال ضحيه جديده
يقدر عدد الضحايا في المدينه حتى الان
بنحو 170 والاعداد مرشحه للارتفاع انهار
اكثر من 300 مبنى سكني وتجاري بشكل كامل
في مالاتيا تتشابه مشاهد الدمار في المدن
المنكوبه وحيث ما وليت وجهك تقابلك قصص
تفيض الما وحزنا قصص تختلف في تفاصيلها
لكن المشترك بينها
هو التعلق بامل
محاصر تحت الانقاض سلام خضر الجزيره
ملاطيا جنوب تركيا
ينضم الينا عبر الهاتف من اسطنبول مجاهد
شاهين مدير العلاقات الخارجيه في هيئه
الاغاثه الانسانيه سيد شاهين مرحبا بك
معنا في الساعات الاخيره هل منا جينا من
تحت الركام
اولا نشكركم على اهتمامكم معنا بخصوص
تفضل
اولا نشكركم على اهتمامكم بخصوص اهتمامنا
في
الحادث الكبير
[موسيقى]
للزلزال وطبعا نقدم
تعازينا لكل اوائل
المتضرره في الزلزال هذا في تركيا وكمان
في سوريا
طبعا كما تعرفون بعض الزلزال اول 72 ساعه
مهم جدا
والعمل البحث والانقاذ مازال مستمر
بالساحه
وخاصه في
خلال الايام الشتاء هناك برد قارس لذلك
اريد ان اشكر كل الفريق الدوليه
التي يساهمنا هناك بالساحه في هذه الليله
البارده
وهل سجلتم خلال الساعات هذه وهي ساعات
حاسمه ونحن نقترب من اليوم الثالث خروج
ناجين من تحت الركام
طبعا ما زال موجود
ركام لكن الاحصائيات الاخيره هناك
[موسيقى]
حاليا انا الاحصائيات الدقيقه ليس موجوده
بصراحه لكن نعرف ان هذا طبعا ضرار كبير
وارقام هائله جدا لكن تضررت عشره مدن
ومئه كيلو متر مربع وهذا تقريبا 13 مليون
شخص تضرر من هذا الزلزال الكبير لكن حاليا
خاصه في الساعات الابتدائيه ليست موجوده
ايدينا
الاحسائيات الدقيقه لكن عندما تتوضح
الصوره
نتوقع انه سيكون الاعداد كبيره جدا
ونتمنى
ونرجو من الله ان نكون العدد قليل
بعد كل هذه الاجراءات
طيب همم في عمليات الاغاثه ما هي
الاولويات بالنسبه لكم
بنسبه لنا طبعا نحن كفريق
نشتغل هناك
باسنا 62 فريق وال 1400 متطوع تقريبا
واثنان كلب الانقاذ
20012 سياره النقل وخاصه هناك المطبخ
المتنقل موجود ويستطيع ان يطبخ هناك عشرين
شخص
يعني عشرين وجبه لعشرين شخص يوميا
وكمان هناك اثنين خيمه الطبيه موجوده لكن
حاليا كما تعرفون
ان هناك خاصه
بتنسيق افات
اكثر الاحتياجات هناك الادوات الايوائيه
مثل
الخيم والبطانيات
والسخان
الغذاء وكمان
الفريق البحث والانقاذ كثير من الفروق
يشتغل هناك يعمل
لانقاذ الاشخاص هناك
وكمان هؤلاء يحتاجون الى الادوات
[موسيقى]
والمعدات البحثيه
بالنسبه
يعني الجثث التي تخرج من تحت الركام
الضحايا الذين لم يتم التعرف عليهم كيف
يجري التعامل معهم
هناك
من طرف الوزاره اعلنوا ان اذا لم يعين له
الهويه هويته سوف يكون له
الجنازه المجموعه يعني مجموع الجنازه
مجموعيه وسيكون الدفن المجموعه
لكن
الذين يعرفون هويتهم سيكون النقل وحتى
الان موجود
النقل الى مدنهم
ما اهم ما وصلكم من المساعدات التي
قدمت لكم من العديد من الدول
هناك كثير من
الكثير من الدول الاوروبيه الجنوبيه
الشرق الاوسط بشكل عام ان هناك فريق البحث
والانقاذ وخاصه متخصصين
وهناك فريق الطبي موجود هؤلاء كما تعرفون
اولا يعني في اول الزلزال
حتى لا يكون هناك ازمه نحن كمان نصحح ان
يكون يعني ان يذهب الى ان ينزل الساحه
الاشخاص المتخصصين في هذا الموضوع
حتى نمنع الازمه لذلك حاليا ومن طرفنا او
من طرف
المنظمات المدنيه والمنظمات الدوليه هناك
موجود فريق البحث والانقاذ
ما زالوا وبلا انقطاع يشتغلون شكرا جزيلا
لك من اسطنبول مجاهد شاهين مدير العلاقات
الخارجيه في هيئه الاغاثه الانسانيه
في اخبارنا الاخرى من العالم قال رئيس
الفرنسي ايمانويل ماكرون في مؤتمر صحفيا
عقده صحبه ضيفيه الرئيس الاوكراني فلودي
والمستشار الالماني اولا
ناروسيا لن تقدر على الفوز بالحرب ولا يجب
ان يحدث ذلك بالمره وان اوكرانيا بامكانها
التعويل على فرنسا وشركائها من اجل الفوز
بالحرب مؤكدا ان دعم اوكرانيا بالعتاد
العسكري سيستمر وسيتم مواءمته حسب
التطورات وكان رئيس الاوكراني فلودي قد
اجتمع في وقت سابق اليوم في لندن مع رئيس
الوزراء البريطاني ريشيسوناك وفي مؤتمر
صحفي مشترك قال سوناك ان بريطانيا مستعده
لمناقشه كل شيء يتعلق الامر بدعم اوكرانيا
عسكريا في اشاره الى قضيه ارسال طائرات
مقاتله الى
نقلت وكاله عن الرئيس الاوكراني قوله ان
رئيس الوزراء البريطاني عبر عن رغبته في
ان يكون قادرا على دعم شكرا يا بمقاتلات
اعلنت بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في ليبيا
اعتمادا اللجنه العسكريه المشتركه 5 + 5
بحضور لجنه التواصل الليبيه ونظيرتيها من
النيجر والسودان في القاهره اليه متكامله
للتنسيق المشترك في جمع وتبادل البيانات
بشان المرتزقه والمقاتلين الاجانب ووصف
رئيس البعثه بعثه الامم المتحده للدعم في
ليبيا عبد الله باتيلي ما توصلت اليه
اللجنه العسكريه المشتركه بانه تقدم
ايجابي يؤدي الى خلق مناخ مواطن للعمليه
السياسيه وتنظيم الانتخابات العام الجاري
وزير الخارجيه الامريكيه عقب لقاء عقدته
وفد من المبعوثين الدوليين مع قوى الحريه
والتغيير المجلس المركزي قال ان بلاده
تدعم الاتفاق السياسيه الايطاليه في
السودان باعتباره الاساس الامثل لتشكيل
حكومه مدنيه قادره على اخراج السودان من
الازمه الاقتصاديه والسياسيه التي يعيشها
نحن ممثلي ومبعوثي كل من فرنسا والنرويج
والمانيا والمملكه المتحده والاتحاد
الاوروبي والولايات المتحده نؤكد دعمنا
للاتفاق السياسي الايطالي الذي يعتبر
الاساس الامثل لتشكيل حكومه مدنيه وتاسيس
الترتيبات الدستوريه للفتره الانتقاليه
واجراء الانتخابات نامل الاسراع في تشكيل
حكومه مدنيه لاخراج السودان من الازمه
الاقتصاديه والسياسيه الحاليه
طلبت بلديه الاحتلال في القدس محكمه
الشؤون المحليه باصدار امر فوري لهدم طابق
وقبه في مسجد عبد الرحمن في بلده بيت
صفصافه جنوب القدس المحتله واستجابت بلديه
الاحتلال لمطالبات منظمات يمينيه
الشيطانيه بهدم قبه المسجد بدعوى انها
تشبه القبه الذهبيه في مسجد قبه الصخره
بالمسجد الاقصى وقال مسؤولون في مسجد عبد
الرحمن ان البلديه تنوي ايضا هدم طابق في
المسجد تبلغ مساحته 700 متر بدعوى عدم
الترخيص
[موسيقى]
حاضر